[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici les
titres de ce vendredi 15 septembre
impensable il ya encore quelques
semaines le projet de la future ligne 18
du grand paris express qui doit
notamment desservir l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines semble
aujourd'hui menacée le gouvernement
pourrait reculer sur le projet pour des
raisons économiques
michel dupart et d'autres invités fil
rouge pour cette émission conseiller
municipal de la majorité à droite la
poisse il est également troisième sur la
liste de la république en marche dans
les yvelines nous évoquerons avec lui le
scrutin et les ambitions du mouvement
fondé par emmanuel macron enfin dans le
reste de l'actualité locale retour
évidemment sur la note des jeux
olympiques à paris saint quentin en
yvelines accueillera plusieurs
compétitions encore la première
manifestation contre les ordonnances sur
la loi du travail organisée par la cgt
on débute cette émission avec l'annoncé
surprise ce vendredi de la démission du
président de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines didier
guillemot quitte son poste pour des
raisons de santé selon un communiqué de
presse nommé en mai 2016 didier
guillemot est remplacé provisoirement
par le vice président du conseil
d'administration de l'université alain
buis une élection interne sera organisée
avant le 14 octobre prochain
je vous le disais en titres nouveaux
rebondissements dans le projet de la
ligne 18 alors que le futur métro du
grand paris express a été déclarée
d'utilité publique il y a quelques mois
seulement
le gouvernement pourrait remettre en
cause le chantier notamment dans les
yvelines c'est en tout cas ce que
laissent entendre certains élus du
département elle les détails avec ce
reportage
et si les yvelinois ne voyait jamais
arrivé la ligne 18 sur leur territoire
voilà une interrogation qui semblait
insensé il ya quelques mois mais qui a
pris corps cet été à la recherche de
plusieurs milliards d'euros d'économies
l'état pourrait annoncer une remise en
cause du projet dans sa partie
yvelinoise un retour en arrière sur fond
de tensions entre départements
franciliens les élus du département
points directement leurs collègues et ce
lien qui pousserait l'état se retirer du
ddt
sié nous avons des bruits qui arrive
jusqu'à nos oreilles comme quoi les
parlementaires essonniens pèserait
auprès du gouvernement pour revoir ces
choses-là dont nous faisons entendre
haut et fort que nous nous voulons cette
ligne 18,6 au napa 2018
on pourra plus continuer à se développer
tout simplement dont plus de
construction de logements plus de deux
entreprises et qui vont venir et donc on
risque d'avoir un déclin de notre
territoire
pour l'heure sans annonce officielle
contraire la ligne 18 du grand paris
express reste un chantier pharaonique de
35 km de métro automatique
traversant trois départements et qui
reliera d'ici 2030 l'aéroport d'orly
dans le val de marne à la gare de
versailles chantiers dans les yvelines
l'état prend des engagements il n'y a
pas de continuité républicaine un
nouveau gouvernement arrive et c'est
plus les mêmes sondages alors bien
entendu
tiens changement gouvernement il ya des
changements de politique mêlée politique
qui s'étale sur 10 15 20 30 ans si
l'état ne les respectent pas il se passe
rien à saint quentin en yvelines en tout
cas les travaux préparatoires sur
l'ancien site de thalès qui doit
accueillir la future gare ont débuté en
vue notamment des jeux olympiques de
2024 l'agglomération accueillera
plusieurs compétitions olympiques
enfin à plus court terme la zone doit
servir de point relais pour la règle
d'or que prévu dans un an
la préparation donc de ces travaux
amorce finalement le début des travaux
pour la ligne 18 que l'on espère voir
débuter en 2018
puisque la ligne est prévue pour 2030
mais tout est fait techniquement pour
que la ligne puisse arriver en 2024
on espère que les annonces du
gouvernement iront dans ce sens dans les
prochains mois enjeux politiques
économiques et sportifs
l'avenir de la ligne 18 ne sont plus si
évident aujourd'hui les arbitrages du
gouvernement sont attendus dans les
prochaines semaines et non sans rapport
pierre bédier le président les
républicains du conseil départemental
des yvelines s'est exprimé il y a
quelques jours devant la presse sur les
différentes actualités nationales et
locales en servir de mantes-la-jolie a
notamment dénoncé la politique du
gouvernement envers les collectivités
territoriales contrats aidés ou encore
baisse des dotations
je vous propose de l'écouter président
de la république d'abord à engager un
gigantesque plan social
parce qu'il faut appeler les choses par
leur nom plan social sans préavis sans
indemnités de licenciement ce sont
l'ensemble des emplois aidés qui sont
indispensables au fonctionnement des
collectivités et qui contrairement à ce
que prétend madame le ministre du
travail donne des résultats
en tout cas des résultats sensible je
peux en témoigner comme ancien maire de
mantes et comme présidente du conseil
départemental
ça c'est une première chose on nous
annonce ensuite d'accroître encore les
économies réalisées on a fait 10
milliards dans le précédent quinquennat
on nous demande d'en réaliser 13
or l'état lui ne respecte pas ni ses
engagements d'économies ni ses
engagements vis-à-vis des collectivités
et pour parler notamment de ses
critiques envers la politique d'
emmanuel macron nous accueillons michel
dupart notre invité aujourd'hui bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes candidat aux élections
sénatoriales vous êtes troisième sur la
liste de la république en marche mais
vous êtes aussi je le disais en
présentation conseiller municipal de la
majorité à poissy majorité de droite
majorité dirigée par karl olive bras
droit de pierre bédier qui vient à
l'instant on l'a entendu critiquer
emmanuel macron c'est un petit peu
compliqué alors je voulais savoir
comment comment vous vous analyser tout
ça n'est ce pas difficile à gérer comme
situation pour vous alors tout d'abord
pour démarrer je voudrait excuser notre
tête de liste martin léveillé qui ne
peut pas être présent aujourd'hui je
remplace sécurité qui finalement j'avais
fait un bon au moins quelqu'un est
présent et c'est une ville de sarcelles
en réunion de travail à l'elysée il peut
pas être là donc voilà donc non non la
situation n'est absolument pas compliqué
il se trouve qu'en 2014 des majorités
sont arrivés au dans les différentes
villes dans les yvelines
à l'époque effectivement nous avons
décidé j'ai décidé de travailler avec
karl olive
une collaboration qui ce qui se passe
bien mais une collaboration locale
encore une fois et je pense que tous mes
collègues élus locaux comprennent que
dans une majorité
dans une commune c'est une majorité en
règle générale diverses composé de
différentes composantes et puis perdre
ils vont dire comme puis karl olive est
aussi connu pour être un proche en tout
cas d'alain juppé donc plutôt cette
droite titiller vers le centre plutôt
que la droite type wauquiez ou autre je
laisse à karl olive le choix de ses
orientations politiques
enfin le localement en tout cas ça se
passe très très bien pour revenir sur ce
qu'on a entendu de pierre bédier qui
dénonçait une nouvelle baisse des
dotations de 13 milliards d'euros durant
le quinquennat on sait que ça va pas
toucher l'année 2018 l'annoncé a été
faite cet été mais du coup ce sera 13
milliards à trouver d'ici quatre ans
enfin sur les quatre prochaines années
est ce que c'est ce que c'est faisable
concrètement pour les mairies vous qui
êtes conseiller municipal vous
connaissez ces sujets parker j'en suis
sûr est-ce que vous pouvez économiser
aujourd'hui 13 milliard d'euros les
mairies l'ensemble des mairies des
collectivités locales déjà je voudrais
quand même rappeler que
le candidat que soutenait faire bégayer
pierre bédier en l'occurrence françois
fillon proposé 20 milliards mais qui
n'est pas président de la république
aujourd'hui
ok enfin il le soutenait même donc pour
le coup le président était extrêmement
clair il donne un objectif sur 5 ans 2
13 milliards d'économies mais en même
temps ils l'expliquent une méthode de
travail
la méthode de travail c'est la suivante
ces concertations négociations ensuite
loi ensuite évaluation et ensuite
contrôler
on l'a vu dans le cadre des ordonnances
du code du travail
le président de la république avait
annoncé je souhaite que les négociations
se fassent au niveau des entreprises
madame pénicaud prend le sujet elles ont
certes elle négocie et finalement les
ordonnances sortes et les concertations
des négociations vont se faire dans les
branches sauf pour les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés
c'est donc la preuve qu'il y a bien du
grain à moudre
il y a matière à négocier et c'est la
position du gouvernement à l'heure
actuelle alors tv 78 ans nés en est le
témoin on reçoit souvent des polypes des
politiques qui nous disent aujourd'hui
on peut plus on n'en peut plus on est en
baisse tout le temps les budgets les
dotations comment je me pose la question
comment on peut baisser 13 de 13
milliards d'euros encore aujourd'hui les
dotations ou est-ce que où est la marge
de manoeuvre selon vous c'est au sein
des mairies c'est au sein des
départements des régions c'est une
question qu'on a souvent parce que vont
avec marc un ouvrier
nous sommes en ce moment en campagne
nous rencontrons beaucoup de maires et
de hêtres collègues adjoints et
conseillers municipaux
c'est une question qui revient souvent
en clair dans le président a donné un
objectif et cet objectif est atteignable
de manière globale nous avons depuis des
années depuis plus de 15 ans rajouter
des couches successives d'administration
de fonctionnement et notamment que la
réforme territoriale la nouvelle halle
ou un autre nous avons rajouté
des couches supplémentaires au
millefeuille qui créent des dépenses
supplémentaires et en fait l'objectif
rappelez vous quand même le faire dès
que vous êtes en train de nous dire
qu'il ya sûrement un échelon de trop il
y a probablement des choses en trop des
choses à revoir
c'est entre autres le travail que le
débat ne rien faire je ne sais pas vous
le dire puisque en fait en clair c'est
encore une fois je reviens sur la
méthode
c'est là que s'est concerté puis fait en
cfd négocier et nous sénateurs c'est le
rôle c'est le rôle du sénat de faire en
sorte d'écouter les territoires pour
pouvoir porter la parole du territoire
obtenir des amendements lors de
commander des votes
voilà on va évoquer les élections
sénatoriales juste un mot peut-être sur
le sujet qui était diffusé en début
d'émission sur cette ligne 18 est ce que
vous vous avez des informations puisque
pour l'instant ce ne sont que des bruits
de couloir on l'a bien entendu mais des
bruits de couleurs conte l'air vrai
puisque tout le monde en parle
est-ce que vous avez des informations
précises là dessus est ce que vous en
tant qu'élu vous soutiendrez en tant que
sénateur élu vous soutiendrez ce projet
si vous êtes élu alors clairement il n'y
a pas de remise fin je pense qu'il faut
pas pleurer avant d'avoir mal
c'est simple on peut toujours
s'inquiéter tout mais ce qui est
important c'est ce sont les faits alors
effectivement on a certains maires et
pierre bédier le président du conseil
départemental qui qui s'inquiètent je le
conçois en l'occurrence sur les yvelines
que ce soit le député jean noël barrot
où que ce soit nous si demain nous
sommes sénateurs et j'ai bien
l'intention nous y soyons nous
défendrons ce projet nous le porterons
c'est très clair il y va de l'intérêt
non pas du département des yvelines
mais de l'intérêt de la région puisque
par cette ligne par son prolongement
on peut envisager que le territoire de
saclay puisse rejoindre un jour le
territoire de cergy où nous avons deux
pôles universitaires extrêmement
important donc il faut une licence il
faut du bon sens et le bon sens triomphe
toujours
alors devenir sénateur on l'a bien
compris c'est votre objectif vous êtes
troisième de la liste
lrm la république en marche l'objectif
c'est donc le 24 septembre prochain
quelles sont plus globalement le nombre
de sénateurs vous penser concrètement
pouvoir avoir avant l'été on pensait
notamment dans les yvelines qui était
possible d'avoir deux trois sénateurs
aujourd'hui la passe difficile de l'été
semble indiquer que déjà un sénateur
c'est bien d'eux ça serait presque un
exploit
est-ce qu'on se trompe ou alors non
alors on fait pas de pronostic on se bat
sur le terrain aujourd'hui que vous les
élus de terrain le mieux parce que ceux
qui votent on rappelle évidemment non
mais bon c'est quand même une élection
un peu particulier parce qu'on a quand
même douze listes en présence
on avait onze listes en 2011 il se
trouve que globalement sur le terrain ce
qui ressort c'est qu'il y a deux forces
en présence la force d'opposition avec
le président de du sénat actuel voilà et
et la force qui a le soutien de la
majorité présidentielle du président et
du gouvernement et du premier ministre
la république en marche ensemble en
marche président c'est ce qui ressort de
nos contacts au quotidien ces deux
forces en présence qui ressortait à 1 ou
2 sénateurs
est ce que si vous n'avez qu'un seul
sénateur ce serait une déception pour
vous concrètement aujourd'hui il ya six
postes en jeu aujourd'hui quatre à
gauche 4 à droite deux à gauche ça c'est
très compliqué pour la bourse bondir sur
les chronos je veux pas faire de
pronostic
voilà on travaille énormément sur le
terrain on travaille au téléphone on
travaille avec des documents que l'on va
distribuer voilà ça c'est un peu les
oreilles parfois avec les élus locaux
quand on leur dit suppression de la taxe
d'habitation 13 milliard d'euros en
moins et les problèmes dont on parlait
contrat le contact est bon ça siffle pas
on a en a une énorme demande
d'explication et encore une fois je
on parle beaucoup de la méthode la
méthode est bien comprise par nos
collègues élus nous engageons nouveaux
sénateurs dans le cadre de l'objectif
donné par le gouvernement à pouvoir
intervenir d'autant que nous serons
vraiment les seuls représentants élus
est officiellement de la majorité
puisque vous avez effectivement vous
avez d'autres listes qui se prétendent
et majorité
le modem notamment qui se prétendent
majorité mais en l'occurrence c'est
quand même assez cocasse malgré les
trois les trois têtes de liste de ces
listes encore une candidate et à la
commission nationale d'investiture de
remarques et ayant été recalés ont
choisi pour chacun il s'agit d'ailleurs
la rédaction de tv de soixante dix huit
proposera la semaine prochaine un sujet
complet sur l'ensemble des listes je
voulais juste avoir un dernier mot sur
ces élections sénatoriales très
rapidement quelle est votre vision à
vous du rôle du sénateur et du sénat bus
qui on le sait que c'est une chambre à
ces critiques et on sait pas forcément
toujours ce qu'elle fait ce que font les
sénateurs vous comment vous vous
envisagez votre rôle
et puis le rôle de la chambre assez
rapidement s'il vous plaît alors
clairement nous et c'est difficile c'est
difficile mais clairement notre rôle est
de défendre les collectivités
territoriales et de pouvoir encore une
fois dans le cadre fixé par le
gouvernement
nous ne sommes pas des godillots au
contraire on en sera là pour porter la
voix de la voix des territoires obtenir
des amendements faire bouger les lignes
et étant donné qu'ils seront dans la
majorité sera beaucoup plus simple que
dans l'opposition ou dans une pseudo
majorité comme certains le laissent
entendre
michel dupas rester avec nous on passe
au reste de l'actualité de cette fin de
semaine marquée notamment par
l'apparition à montigny le bretonneux de
caméras piéton pour les policiers
municipaux
ce nouveau dispositif doit favoriser la
sécurité des agents en même temps que
lutter plus efficacement contre les
incivilités reportage sur le sujet de
camille lambert
l'agent sa prise au service va percevoir
une caméra il va ensuite inscrire les
éléments de référence sur le registre de
perception
c'est une nouvelle habitude pour eric
piot et ses vingt agents de la police
municipale de montigny le bretonneux des
caméras piétons pour enregistrer leurs
interventions sur le terrain avec
surtout un aspect préventif si certaines
personnes pouvaient
pouvait un certain moment adopter un
comportement plus ou moins virulent ou
injurieux je pense qu il
ils réfléchiront un petit peu avant et
je pense que les choses se passeront
beaucoup plus sereinement
la police municipale est équipé de six
caméras pour une période de test jusqu'à
juin 2010 huit coups de cet outil de
dissuasion 5000 euros investis par la
ville
une mesure nécessaire même si la commune
enregistre une tendance à la baisse de
la délinquance se détendent ce qu ont
été confirmées par la police nationale
donc donc ils sont qui sont fiables
après on a plutôt des des difficultés
ponctuelles à des endroits bien précis
aujourd'hui on constate certaines
évolutions par contre
mauvais comportement sur et aux abords
de la gare ces nouvelles caméras
s'inscrivent comme complément de
sécurisation avec d'autres dispositifs
déjà existants comme les pistolets à
impulsion électrique adopté également à
voisins le bretonneux et la principale
actualité de cette semaine c'est
évidemment l'annoncent officiel de
l'organisation par paris des jeux
olympiques 2024 l agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines accueillera
notamment plusieurs épreuves du 2 au 18
août 2000 24 c dans 74 sites ont été
retenus dans le dossier parisien
le vélodrome nationale la colline
d'elancourt l'île de loisirs mais aussi
le golf national
les détails avec notre journaliste
sportif michael et demi d'euros saint
quentin en yvelines sera à l'honneur
pendant les jo de 2024
quatre sites ont été retenus par les
organisateurs français les épreuves de
cyclisme sur piste seront programmés
dans le vélodrome nationale la structure
inaugure en 2014 a déjà accueilli les
championnats du monde en 2015 et les
championnats d'europe l'année suivante
bien sûr ça à lèves le doute sur sur
toutes les interrogations qu'on pourrait
avoir la l'équipement il est là il a été
testé il a accueilli déjà
la plus grandes échéances
internationales avec les championnats du
monde donc je pense que tout ça c'est
forcément des garanties pour le seuil
haut à une centaine de mètres du
vélodrome il de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines a été sélectionné dans le
dossier paris 2024 pour accueillir les
épreuves masculines et féminines de bmx
une piste modulable sera construite sur
ce terrain vague de sept hectares
ce site a été choisi principalement
parce qu'ils jouent je te le vélodrome
on est on est à 100 mètres à pied du
vélodrome
donc il y aura une parfaite
complémentarité entre les épreuves qui
se dérouleront dans le vélodrome et les
épreuves de bmx ici sans parler du cadre
nature qui s'y prête parfaitement la
colline d'elancourt accueillera quant à
elle les épreuves de vtt le projet dans
les cartons depuis les jo de 2012 a été
ressortie pour la candidature de paris
le site qui culmine à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude fait toujours autant
l'unanimité auprès des organisateurs
pour accueillir les épreuves de vtt
la première force et l'unité de lieu le
deuxième point là ici c'est la
dénivellation et donc le vtt on appelle
ça mountain bike c'est du vélo de
montagne et donc il faut aller chercher
des pentes raides et il ya quasiment
qu'ici qu'on a qu'on a ce que l'on
souhaite pour avoir à quelque chose de
très raide
donc oui c'est assez naturel que ça
vienne ici sur la sur la colline de la
hanche
enfin le golf national recevrait les
épreuves golfique les joueurs
disputeront les parties sur le parcours
de l'albatros le 18 trous réputé comme
l'un des plus compliqués au monde a été
entièrement rénové entre 2015 et 2016
ce challenge de plus c'est une super
compétition et dans l'est
les jo les gones nationale serait le
premier parcours de golf du monde en
dresser wayne ryder cup est légion donc
assez commun mais non ça fait pas peur
c'est simple et mahmoud challenge est
plus à sa savane d'émotion à la vie dans
le reste des yvelines les épreuves
d'équitation de pentathlon moderne se
disputeront à versailles les courses de
cyclisme sur route devrait quant à elle
passer dans la vallée de chevreuse
michel dupart vous me disiez pendant le
pendant le sujet vous et ira vite les
jeux olympiques arriva à paris quel est
le plus important pour vous c'est bon
pour l'image de paris et donc de la
france c'est bon pour l'économie est ce
que c'est bon surtout pour le monde du
sport et le monde du sport français
j'ai envie de dire les trois n'ont cessé
c'est vraiment excellent pour l'image
une image de dynamisme une image qui
projette vers l'extérieur une très belle
image de la france une france
conquérante une france qui gagne tout ce
qu'on veut et tout ce que nous je savais
que j'étais à l'image d'emmanuel macron
ça d'ailleurs est ce que vous pensez
petit aparté politique
honnêtement et foncer vers la violence
c'est même tout à fait secondaire ce qui
est important c'est la france emmanuel
macron et le porteur de la france
aujourd'hui mais c'est l'image de la
france qui est importante voilà
l'économie on aura des retombées
alors ça fait bien toujours oui la
polémique sur j'aurais pu légitimer le
coût réel
oui mais vous semblez que le dossier par
exemple à soit mieux ficelé que les
anciens dossiers en tout cas l'avantagé
nous avons au moins 85% des structures
existantes
donc il y à des investissements des
investissements qui seront
essentiellement dans le 93 et notamment
qui serviront
2 par la suite pour les logements et
pour les infrastructures pour les
habitants donc c'est que du positif
l'autre grande actualité de la semaine
c'était mardi est la première
manifestation contre la nouvelle réforme
du code du travail entre 220 milles et
quatre cent mille personnes ont
manifesté en france selon les différents
chiffres attrape la section locale de la
cgt organisé un départ depuis le parking
devant la mairie reportage
le rendez vous était donné sur un
parking dans une ambiance calme à
l'heure du déjeuner près d'une
soixantaine de personnes ont répondu
présent au départ organisé à trappes par
la cgt 78 et l'organisation au point
retraités salariés ou chômeurs soit
faire passer leur message tenir bon
malgré la détermination répétées du
gouvernement à réformer le code du
travail par ordonnance la rue fera
reculer un jour ou l'autre même si avec
la loi comme rit ou on a eu beaucoup de
manifestations n'a pas fait reculer mais
il le paiera cher quand même un moment
ou un autre et la cgt a déjà prévenu une
nouvelle journée de manifestations est
prévue le 21 septembre prochain la
veille de la présentation du projet en
conseil des ministres dans le détail la
réforme du code du travail prévoit 36
mesure pour le renforcement du dialogue
social selon le nom officiel avec
notamment le plafonnement des indemnités
prud'homale la fusion des différentes
instances représentatives du personnel
ou encore la possibilité de mise en
place de contrats de chantier c'est
aussi enfin et surtout plus de
négociations possibles au coeur des plus
petites entreprises
les accords des accords de branche et
accor disons que j'étais nationaux
seront balayés pour des accords
d'entreprise malheureusement
heureusement dans beaucoup d'entreprises
ya beaucoup moins de la peau de
syndicats ou inexistants et bien là ce
sera la loi du patron
voilà selon le calendrier souhaité par
le gouvernement les ordonnances devrait
rentrer en vigueur dès le 25 septembre
prochain
michel dupart au lieu au delà du nombre
de manifestants que les lieux mardi au
delà on va dire du projet qui va
forcément se mettre en place à partir du
25 septembre prochain est ce que
emmanuel macron n'at-il pas fait une
grave erreur en déclarant vous le savez
qu'il ne reculerait pas devant les
cyniques les extrêmes et puis surtout ce
mot qui fait polémique depuis les
fainéants
est-ce qu'il n'a pas renforcé
l'opposition finalement en faisant cette
déclaration c'est une erreur de
communication assez grave quand même
pour on va dire le prodige de la
communication non il faut remettre ça
dans le contexte est là encore on attend
des cadets voyez on a tendance à dévoyer
les choses c'est pareil sur irma on a
beaucoup reproché plus finalement quand
on fait la comparaison entre la france
et la hollande la france a mis quatre
fois plus de moyens
finalement ça va calmer la polémique là
encore ce mot utilisé se référer aux
fainéants et aux cyniques qui ont dirigé
notre pays et qui l'ont amené dans le
mur et ça se travaille c'est pas du tout
aux travailleurs et aux français en
général
voilà donc il faut remettre ça dans le
contexte encore une fois en tout cas
pour vous c'est une réforme qui vous
semble bonne et qui va relancer la
machine emplois en france vous en est
persuadé en tout cas c'est une réforme
qui a une double validation la
validation parce que le candidat
emmanuel macron l'avait annoncé donc
c'était connu de tout le monde
et deuxièmement parce que ça a été voté
les ordonnances ont été votées après une
âpre discussions et des négociations qui
ont même fait évoluer la ligne et les
annonces qui avaient été faites par le
candidat président merci michel dupart
d'être venu en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes troisième sur la liste de la
république en marche pour les élections
sénatoriales dans les yvelines
merci à vous mardi emmanuel macron s'est
rendu aux antilles suite au passage dire
ma le président a pu mesurer parfois la
colère de certains habitants et afficher
son soutien aussi avec les autorités
locales sur place le déblaiement a
débuté avec l'aide notamment de treize
pompiers yvelinois nous recevions mardi
soir sur notre plateau pendant le
journal le chef du centre de secours et
d'incendié de chanteloup-les-vignes
extrait dans l'émission sur place sont
de la distribution de vivres dans un
premier temps et puis après c'est de
rétablir les axes de circulation qui
sont des priorités et puis de faire du
bâchage de renforcement de structures
aussi et en même temps d'installer un
camp de base pour que nos personnes
puissent aussi s'installer et avoir un
minimum d'hygiène porte le
la mission puisse s'installer dans le
temps donc le 13 pompiers il veut nous
envoyer c'est une mission qui va durer
combien de temps là-bas sur plein
d'autres responsables sont engagés sur
une durée de 15 jours et nous sommes en
train de d'anticiper la relève pour que
des gens puissent continuer sur place
sur un format équivalent sur une relève
là qui dura 21 jours qui devrait arriver
la semaine prochaine sur un paria un
format de douze à treize personnes
environ qui viendront donc compléter le
travail continue et parce que
effectivement beaucoup de travail comme
vous le savez sur place et la fin de ce
set 8 l'hebdo retour de l'information en
direct lundi sur tv 60 18 à 18 heures
d'ici là restez informés et connecté
grâce à notre site internet et nos
applications tv 78 bon ok là tous et à
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]